ganz offen posieren Jugendliche mit
Hitlergruß auf dem Sportplatz der
Gemeinde Burg im Spreewald ein Foto von
Schülern das sie selbst aufgenommen und
auf Social Media Plattformen verbreitet
haben in ihrer Schule Hakenkreuze an den
Wänden Naziparolen auf schuleipets
rechtsextreme rassistische und homophobe
Symbole im klassenchat
[Musik]
in unserem E-Mail-Postfach finden wir
einen anonymen Brandbrief zwei Lehrer
machen darin bekannt was an dieser
Schule den Alltag bestimmt
tagtäglich sind wir damit beschäftigt
Schüler vor psychischer und physischer
Gewalt zu schützen
wir treffen sie zum Interview aus Angst
vor arbeitsrechtlichen Konsequenzen
wollen sie unerkannt bleiben
Schüler zeigen auf den Schulflur in den
Hitlergruß sie grenzen systematische
Schüler aus die demokratische Werte
vertreten und schicke Ihnen natürlich
auch Schüler die nicht aus Deutschland
kommen
das Interview ist ein Hilferuf denn die
beiden Pädagogen fühlen sich mit
dem allein gelassen
ich kritisiere an manchen Kollegen dass
sie nicht hinschauen das ist vielleicht
auch zum Alltag für sie geworden ist
dass sie blind geworden sind auf dem
rechten Auge und das oftmals Rechte
Taten als Jugendstreich dahingestellt
werden
wir wollen uns selbst ein Bild machen
und begeben uns auf den Weg nach Burg in
den Spreewald
hier in der Region gibt es kaum
Arbeitslose vieles ist in Bewegung
die Bundesregierung investiert 40
Milliarden Euro in die ehemaligen
braunkohlegebiete
abgehängt sieht anders aus
wir erreichen Burg ein idyllischer Ort
der hauptsächlich vom Tourismus lebt
wir fahren zur Grund- und Oberschule
Schüler mit Migrationshintergrund gibt
es hier kaum wir treffen auf einen Mann
und fragen ihn ob er von dem Brandbrief
gehört hat
kann dazu nichts großartig sagen für
mich sind da die Schüler alle völlig
normal
schnell wird klar warum er rechtes
Gedankengut in den Klassenzimmern für
normal hält er und seine beiden
Mitstreiter werden offen für die
neonazistische Kleinpartei der dritte
Weg der Verfassungsschutz stuft die
Mehrheit ihrer Mitglieder als höchst
gewaltbereit ein wir werden Zeuge wie
sie Flyer an die Schüler verteilen
schließlich kommt die Polizei und er
teilt einen Platzverweis mehr können die
Behörden nicht tun
warum sind die Jugendlichen hier so
empfänglich für Rechtsextremismus die
amadeo Antonio Stiftung beschäftigt sich
schon seit Jahren mit dieser Frage
es wäre viel zu kurz gegriffen jetzt das
Problem allein bei den Jugendlichen und
den Kindern zu suchen es muss immer
geschaut werden wo es herkommt und
gerade wenn wir uns jetzt die Region
über die wir gerade reden zum Beispiel
im Spreewald der anschauen da gibt es
eine lebhafte rechtsextreme Szene und
die dort leben und diese Szene bilden
das sind die Eltern dieser Jugendlichen
ja dieser Rechtsextremismus der wird
vererbt ja der wird eben nicht
konsequent aufgearbeitet der wurde seit
den 90er Jahren nicht konsequent
aufgearbeitet und wurde eben auch nicht
genügend tabuisiert
direkt gegenüber der Schule in Burg für
die Freundin des Neonazis Daniel Kretz
eine Eisdiele
er soll zur militanten
rechtsextremenszene im Raum Cottbus
gehören
auch das traditionsreiche deutsche Haus
wird von ihm Betrieben ein Restaurant am
Ortseingang
[Musik]
die Gemeinde sieht keinen Grund dem
Neonazi das zu verbieten sagt
Amtsdirektor Tobias Hentschel wir haben
sag mal
mailandsfreiheit in Deutschland aber
auch im Bereich der Wirtschaft kann man
im wirtschaftlich sich betätigen auch
weil man eine gewisse Hintergrund hat
und insofern sind uns als Kommunen dann
immer die Hände gebunden wir können das
nur beobachten begleiten wenn Vorfälle
bekannt werden
rechtsextreme beobachten und begleiten
im turniert stattdessen ist die
Situation so eskaliert dass zwei Lehrer
mit einem Brandbrief an die
Öffentlichkeit gehen mussten erst
nachdem Medien den Fall bekannt machten
erstattete die Schulleitung Anzeige
wegen der hitlergrüße und den rechten
Parolen warum so lange geschwiegen wurde
beschäftigt auch den Verfassungsschutz
wir treffen Leiter Jörg Müller zum
Interview
überrascht hat uns bedauerlicherweise
nicht wer als Verfassungsschutz haben ja
schon seit längerem in der Region und in
den Bereich davor gewarnt dass dort
Rechtsextremisten aktiv sind das ist
dort Strukturen gibt die weit über die
Bereiche der normalen Rechtsextremisten
hinausgehen und sich dort auch
vergegenwärtigt haben beispielsweise
Gaststätten betreiben Restaurants
gekauft haben Hotels betreiben aber auch
sonstige Akteure das richtige aktiv sind
und haben davor gewarnt
unterdessen erreicht uns per WhatsApp
ein zweiter Hilferuf aus Burg diesmal
von schüler:innen es herrschte ein Klima
der Angst beschreiben sie darin
im Landesschülerrat Brandenburg kennen
sie solche Probleme auch von anderen
Schulen also bei uns im Landesschülerrat
ist es fast bei jeder Sitzung Thema
einfach weil es uns allen auf dem Herzen
brennt und wir in den Schulen ist
teilweise tagtäglich erleben und
natürlich deshalb irgendwelche
Lösungsansätze finden möchten
Brandenburgs Bildungsminister kündigt
Aufklärung und Maßnahmen an ein
Interview dazu gibt er uns nicht
jährlich bis zu 54 extremistische
Vorfälle an Brandenburgs Schulen
registrierte das Bildungsministerium in
den vergangenen Jahren nur die Spitze
des Eisbergs vermuten Experten
wir haben da ein Problem und das überall
in Deutschland in Brandenburg ist es
jetzt ganz besonders schlimm weil auch
diese Schule in einem wirklichen Szene
Hotspot das Rechtsextremismus ist aber
eigentlich muss jetzt mal flächendeckend
geguckt werden wo ist das Problem und
wie ausgeprägt ist das Burg kein
Einzelfall ist zeigt sich wenige Tage
später in der Jugendherberge Kiez am
Frauensee eine Schulklasse aus Berlin
reist mitten in der Nacht ab weil sie
von einer Gruppe Jugendlicher
rassistisch bedroht worden sein soll
viele der Schülerinnen aus der
Kreuzberger Schule haben einen
Migrationshintergrund
wir haben die Gardinen aufgemacht und
haben gesehen dass über das ganze
Gebäude sie um uns herum waren sie waren
eine größeren Gruppe ich vermute so mehr
als 35 50 waren die danach haben sie uns
als bezeichneten eine also dass
wir eine Klatsche bekommen sollen und so
weiter auf die rechtsextreme Gewalt
reagiert so mancher Einwohner nur mit
Schulterzucken
nach ich mach mein Ding und alles ist
gut die Landesregierung antwortet
reflexhaft kündigt Maßnahmen an
wir werden alle Möglichkeiten nutzen die
uns eine starke Demokratie bietet um
gegen solche
Übergriffe vorzugehen der
Verfassungsschutz fordert null toler uns
gegenüber rechter Gewalt
alle Akteure Seins Eltern Seins Schüler
seinen Lehrer sei es die Stadt sei es
der Verfassungsschutz die Polizei müssen
an einen Tisch kommen möglichst schnell
das heißt wir müssen uns den Problemen
stellen
und eine Beratung
eine Betreuung Schule Sozialarbeit
allein wird es nicht reichen wir müssen
sanktionieren wir müssen zeigen dass das
nicht toleriert wird vor Ort wenn jemand
außerhalb der Demokratie
rechtsextremistische Polen schreit wir
sind auf dem Weg nach Oranienburg
gehen Sie das Problem schon lange sehr
kundlehrerin Juliane Reinert im
viktoria-luise-gymnasium sie leitet die
Arbeitsgemeinschaft Toleranz
[Musik]
die SchülerInnen wollen Respekt und
Toleranz in den Rest der Schule tragen
und diskutieren was Ihnen wichtig ist
Freiheit
Gerechtigkeit Toleranz und Ehrlichkeit
denn auch hier an der Schule gab es
schon rechtsextreme Vorfälle hier an der
Schule hat man schon gesehen wie Schüler
die Hitler groß sich gegenseitig ja sich
damit gegrüßt haben einfach gegen
hitlergrüße wird hier Anzeiger erstattet
aber es ist auch wichtig eine Debatte an
der Schule anzustoßen sehr sehr wichtig
ist dass wir das thematisieren und dass
wir das Reflektieren und versuchen
gemeinsam zu überlegen wie wollen wir
eigentlich leben und wie wollen wir
nicht leben und ich glaube dass wir das
in der AG über Projekte ganz gut
realisieren können und eben darüber auch
eine breiten Wirkung in der Schule
entfalten können und hoffentlich andere
dann positiv beeinflussen können nicht
an allen Schulen finden sich Lehrkräfte
die Zeit haben so viel in die politische
Bildung der Jugendlichen zu investieren
doch das wäre bitter nötig
Lehrer und Schüler fordern schon seit
langem mehr Raum im Lehrplan für die
Vermittlung von demokratischen Werten
auch hier bei der Kundgebung vor dem
Schulamt in Cottbus eine Handvoll Bürger
Lehrer und Schüler will ein Zeichen
gegen Rechtsextreme Vorfälle in der
Region und besonders in Schulen setzen
für die diese Demo steht weil wir gegen
Diskriminierung sind weil wir halt
allgemein einfach die Situation scheiße
finden die auf Schulen jetzt einfach
vorgefallen ist das wollen wir wenn ich
unterstützen und ein Zeichen setzen die
beiden Verfasser des brandbriefs haben
ihren Job aufs Spiel gesetzt weil sie
den Dienstweg nicht eingehalten haben
heute trauen Sie sich und zeigen ihr
Gesicht mit Konsequenzen müssen sie laut
Bildungsministerium nicht rechnen Schule
ist meines Abbild der Gesellschaft und
wenn die Gesellschaft mit Hakenkreuzen
versehen ist dann haben wir ein Problem
das hatten wir schon mal
während die einen für Demokratie und
Vielfalt demonstrieren postiert sich der
AFD kreis-chef oben auf der Brücke und
beobachtet das Geschehen
er ist dem Verfassungsschutz gut bekannt
denn er hat Verbindungen ins extrem
rechte Milieu er soll das Denken der
Schüler nicht bestimmen Extremisten wie
ihm keine Chance geben dafür stehen sie
heute hier